a whole bunch of the hooks that you hear
that i gave to people be like it'd be a
story behind the type of [ __ ] like too
many years to call that black [ __ ]
mm-hmm i wrote that [ __ ] i was literally
about to get sentenced you know what i'm
saying like i'm in the [ __ ] box with
everybody that's about to go to see the
judge you feel me i'm like damn i didn't
give these [ __ ] too many years
already and i'm about to go get
sentenced again like this [ __ ]
you feel me so i'm thinking of this [ __ ]
while i'm about to go see the judge and
i'm making the melody everybody in there
like [ __ ] you singing like that [ __ ] so
hot
i let everybody in their hair [ __ ]
like yo that [ __ ] deep bro like you
gotta go homie
like you gotta go crazy with that one
right there so i had this in the cup for
a minute i ain't never really dropped
that [ __ ] like when i came home because
i ain't had a right beat in my head i
heard like a specific beat right and i
couldn't ever find that [ __ ] you feel me
so i'm with this [ __ ] jay graham that's
my guy shout out to jay graham you
clutch yeah um i'm just in the cribby
highest [ __ ] this one when i used to
recording the cradle with him i'm just
like bro i'm trying to do this one hook
that i got bro can you please find a
beat for me you're like bro i can't i
can't like i can make a beat around it
i'm like well that [ __ ] ain't gonna work
you feel me like for me so you like just
try like just sing it and i'm gonna make
the beat around it i'm alright [ __ ] it i
said put the metronome on you know
metronome was like yeah
yeah i just sung the hook to that [ __ ]
you heard me cause i couldn't find no
beat bro he made the whole beat
surrounded that [ __ ] wow
[ __ ] bro i'm like damn the whole hook
and sometimes and that's never that
never happens usually it's the beat
starts or like a loop and then you do it
so so he made the beat to your yeah
under me that's crazy we had this [ __ ]
and i'm like dude it's probably one of
the biggest hooks i got right now you
know what i'm saying like i mean oh like
me and orlando we like damn like what we
gonna do with this [ __ ] like we gotta
like if we go
with if we go the way we wanna go it's
not gonna go how we wanted to go you
know what i'm saying because they're not
really pushing pushing pushing for my
[ __ ] right now
so i'm like man who the next [ __ ] like
that you [ __ ] with this like could
tell this story for us you feel me like
because i i'm i don't want this to be my
song at this point i wanna yeah i want
to be big and i want this [ __ ] the world
to hear this [ __ ]
so you like to sign this kid called that
black bro you don't fire
like let me listen to this [ __ ] i listen
to this i'm like bro he perfect for this
[ __ ] like let's go meet this [ __ ] so i
linked up with kodak
and he got on that [ __ ] he was like
he was amazing he didn't really [ __ ]
with [ __ ] at this point like at this
point
like i feel like he's kind of always
been like that yeah he he was on
somebody like
very interesting guy this [ __ ] yeah
yeah
but when he heard my [ __ ]
he was like damn like this [ __ ]
different you feel me like i ain't never
i ain't know you was coming like that
and it was just like we started [ __ ]
with each other on that level and we
always continued to make music after
that
but that was like i got a lot of stories
like the everyday relationship that was
like my song you feel me like me in the
studio i mean we could tell me and every
man me and wyff and lucci in the studio
that's my session you from i just caught
him because i [ __ ] with his music you
showed me like we met in atlanta i seen
that he was in new york while i was in
new york i caught him deep deep and [ __ ]
man for me you know i turned that [ __ ]
up from the rip he played the beat i
just went in you feel me just went right
in the booth like this
and then he came and followed me and
then we just was going back and forth
back and forth it was supposed to be my
song you could tell by the way it was
structured like right
i actually had to take my voice and put
his second type [ __ ] but it was like
i already knew what they was going to do
with that [ __ ] you felt me like they was
going heavy in the strip clubs and heavy
in the promotion in atlanta like as far
as like just paying dj's to play his
shot yeah you know i think it's a game
they they
you know i mean i'm saying their run's
not over but during that time
well they had they had they got the
formula i was like at that point in time
they had a lot to prove too because
they had to show people that the rich
homie quan [ __ ] wasn't just a one-time
thing
you know what i'm saying so it was like
perfect timing i think